today you can start doing the right
thing right now
our choices impact the future
this culture does not one that supports
healthy human growth
there is a tight connection between
feeling anxious and not allowing love to
come in
trauma is something that leaves the
brain different going forward
influence is much much more valued than
creativity and that sucks
hey everybody happy holidays from myself
and my team here in podcast landia we've
really enjoyed revisiting these
conversations and putting together this
special auditory yearbook for all of you
and part two does not disappoint
compiling this Anthology every year is a
sacred process for me and I'm so proud
of all the amazing conversations we've
hosted and the enormous growth of this
podcast and this recap practice is just
one way that I can honor the magic that
we make here together and it's kind of a
reminder of the power we all have to do
and be better so with this in mind enjoy
part two of our best of 2022 edition of
the Rich Roll podcast starting with the
Lord of All Things overlooked and
misunderstood the great and just
frustratingly multi-talented journalist
author podcaster and Runner Mr Malcolm
Gladwell
when it comes to evaluating the
greatness of elite performers we over
emphasize Peak Performance and
underemphasize
uh longevity so
I got an I sometimes participate in the
web the let's run running outside yes
well this came up in your in in the kind
of extended blog post interview that you
did with David epster and then let's Ron
kind of erupted an outrage over your
your thesis here they are so wrong and I
am so right so I said that the Miler
Nick Willis
quote does not belong in the same
conversation as Matt Centris in other
words Willis is up here sensuous is a
step below even though everyone said
we'll send Matt Century to one the gold
medal in the 1500 meters
how can you say that Nick Willis who has
never won a gold medal in any games is
his equal and I would say well
the answer is that
Matt Sanchez had one great Shining
Moment that gold medal and he was a
relevant runner for a kind of three four
year window and had one very very fast
1500 meters that he ran Nick Willis was
relevant for 15 years
his top he he had a he doesn't have a
goal but he had a silver and a bronze in
two separate Olympics separated by a lot
of years he was a threat to win almost
any race he entered from you know for
over a decade his top three times are
all faster than Matt Sanchez's times
he's broken four minutes for the mile in
20 consecutive years
and I think as a culture we are somehow
dismissive of long periods of Elite
Performance and infatuated with brief
Windows of extraordinary Elite
Performance and I think that's wrong
right well of course being you know as
we're as we're getting older we have a
longevity bias right David accuses you
of being you know this is this is you
know of course you're gonna over index
on this because we're getting old right
absolutely 100 but it goes back to the
beginning of our conversation when we
were talking about kids sports right
like we over index on the highest
performers and we're not paying
attention to how we how we kind of
inject these experiences with joy to
create lifelong Pursuits exactly so
imagine you're right this is exactly the
kind of same conversation imagine that
rich I make you the you know athletic
head at one of these local high schools
and you stand up in front of the entire
school on your first day in the job what
is the speech you give right now I'm
gonna I'm gonna put words I know you're
gonna You're Gonna Write the speech for
me yeah well I know what you're gonna
say you're gonna say I am here to create
in you teenagers a set of habits around
physical exercise that will stay with
you for the rest of your life right
how to be I am going to teach you I'm
going to use my job as athletic director
to teach you how to live a healthy life
by and you're talking about healthy in a
sense of physical exercise but all those
things as well because that leads you
into
psychological health emotional health
that's your goal you're you are not
going to say I'm going to try and win as
many California state titles over the
next five years as I possibly can right
you're not going to give that and that
and the tragedy is that everybody else
who gets that job says I'm here to win
as many California titles as I can over
the next five years everyone should give
the speech you give that's the that is
the speech that's not being given and
that and we are suffering as a country
as a society as a result we look around
you one percent of the population in
Middle Ages practicing healthy habits
why is that because no one bothered to
teach them at the moment when those
habits need to be taught
right so this whole my argument about
Nick Willis the idea of having a
standard of performance that that spans
20 years that matters why because Nick's
going to be when he's 70 Nick's going to
be healthy and running and competing in
in and that's what I want I don't care
whether he's winning at 70. but the idea
that he could put together a portfolio
of running that starts in his teens and
ends in his 70s is something that makes
me
so just
proud to be part of the same group of
Runners as he is well the animating
force behind longevity is Joy right like
you can't have a long-standing career at
a high bar unless you're enjoying what
you're doing right so we we have seen
you know outstanding excellent
performances from people who reach the
very Peak but then they burn out or they
hate what they're doing and they walk
away from it never to you know
participate it in it again so how do you
ignite that level of joy and connection
to that Pursuit that keeps you know
keeps you going so at your age you're
still interested in in running and
training and all of those things and it
brings joy and Community into your life
and if there's a great performance you
know every once in a while that comes
out of that great if not who cares yeah
it's so I like that argument it is you
know it's very gladwellian of course
it's orthogonal to like the way that we
think about these things
um but there is you know you can't be
you can't be intellectually honest about
this unless you recognize that that
occasional you know outstanding
performer
um is the kind of spark that inspires us
all right like for you need the Michael
phelpses and the LeBrons to set this bar
that you know kind of gets us excited
about maybe engaging in that sport to
begin with
yes
um I'm not saying that I'm opposed to
I mean look at how much I talk about
these fantastic track and field athletes
yeah obviously these are important to
you they are but I also recognize that
that though that set of values applied
at the
um to the body of the sport are
counterproductive so I'm what I'm
arguing is for it goes back to the
conversation we have in the very
beginning about cross-country teams
should have 20 people on them and the
20th person should matter as much as the
first that is not a I'm not saying We
Run the World cross-country
championships that way but I do think we
run the middle school and the high
school cross-country championships that
way in other words it's time for us to
understand that there are two very
different models here and that the
models aren't can be contradictory and
we need to find a way to kind of
Foster them both and right now the Elite
model the Peak Performance model is
winning and that is driving a lot of
young people out of the sport and
discouraging a lot of people and
frustrating our attempt to restore the
health of the of our society
2022 marked the second appearance of
self-help Superstar Mel Robbins one of
the most widely booked public speakers
in the world with followers in the
millions Mel is a former lawyer turned
talk show host Mega best-selling author
and now damn her for moving in on my
territory podcast host with a knack for
helping people blow up limiting beliefs
and mindsets
here's Mel on some recent breakthroughs
in her struggle with anxiety
because this is going to lead us right
into the topic about mental health about
mindset about happiness and the the
profound issues I've been working on in
my own life is I
completely understand what you mean when
you say it's really hard to accept a
compliment it's hard to accept a gift
you'd rather have it be about somebody
else
one of the biggest breakthroughs I've
had in the last couple years rich is
this Epiphany about my inability to
receive love and the fact that I was
uncomfortable for a long time
hearing a compliment or having somebody
say something nice or having a birthday
party thrown for me or receiving a gift
and I have recently had this
breakthrough because I have learned that
there is a extremely tight connection
between feeling anxious and not allowing
love to come in and so I have this
visual rich and I'm going to explain
this to you because
um I just had this emotional experience
happen when you sort of were like
pushing away the love I was trying to to
to shower you with so
I think when you block love like imagine
like there's this closed door
and when somebody tries to link with you
or connect with you or authentically
tell you how amazing you are if you have
a hard time hearing it you basically
have put a solid door between you and
the other person
and I've been working recently with
visualizing The Galley doors in a
kitchen That Swing both ways because
you're very good at giving love you're
very good at giving support you're an
incredibly amazing friend because you're
always there when somebody needs you and
you always open the door to listen to
advise to share
and I'm the same way too and for a long
time when somebody would try to give it
back to me the door was closed so let's
talk a little bit about where that comes
from like what is the Genesis of that
instinct for you or what have you
learned about what I've learned about
this and I would strongly encourage you
to bring Dr Russell Kennedy onto your
show he wrote the book anxiety RX he's a
medical doctor who also got his degree
in neuroscience and he started
experiencing anxiety when he was in
medical school and he
um has gone on to heal his anxiety he
treats people around the world with
anxiety like he is a game changer on
this content and the topic of anxiety
so his theory and I now see this
completely in my life his theory is that
all anxiety comes from childhood and it
comes from the experience of being
separate in childhood and so every
single one of us has an experience and
you may not remember it because 80 of
your brain is formed by the time you're
five years old but you have an
experience where you as a kid feel
distinct and separate from your
caregiver and he talks a lot about this
concept of a parental mismatch so there
are a lot of us that have parents who
are wonderful people or maybe they're
not wonderful people but you have
parents who are wonderful people but for
you emotionally just like the five love
languages there can be a mismatch in
terms of the love language you speak and
need and what your partner does that
your parent and the way that they
provide emotional support is a mismatch
and so as a kid when you don't get the
reassurance you need or when you don't
feel loved or seen or heard or accepted
you feel separate from the parent that
you're biologically hardwired and
needing to bond with which also means
you feel unsafe and so as a little kid
at some point an alarm would go off in
your body whenever you felt separate
from your parents and it could be as
innocuous as go hug your uncle and
you're like this I don't want to hug my
uncle you're like get in there
um or don't do that now I'm busy or the
snapping at you and you immediately feel
that alarm because you feel separate
and so what happens is that this alarm
that starts going off and going off and
going off in moments where you feel
separate you're not feeling the love
that you need you're not feeling
connected you're not feeling reassured
it starts to go off all the time
now as you get older and older and older
I mean we've all had the experience of
walking in to see old friends at lunch
and for many of us we feel that alarm go
off they've all arrived there they're
all talking you feel that sense of
Separation that's anxiety
that's what it is it's in your body and
it is according to Dr Kennedy it is the
little you
basically waving their hand saying I
need a little reassurance right now
it's all that it is
and for decades I have approached what
has been an experience of living with
anxiety
from the neck up I mean the five second
rule is a neck up approach and based on
the last two years of intense therapy
that I've been in and you know a lot of
stuff that I've recently learned from Dr
Kennedy I realize it is
fundamentally a neck down issue
that attacking anxiety and these moments
where you feel separate or scared or you
feel the alarm go off in your body if
you instead of treating it like a signal
that something's wrong if you actually
treat it as a signal
that you just need a little bit of love
from yourself right now just put your
hand on your heart you can like take a
towel and kind of do this on your back
rub it back and forth and you feel like
you're hugging yourself take a deep
breath tell yourself whatever you need
to hear in that moment in order to
reassure yourself that you're going to
be okay or that whatever you know I get
it you know you feel a little nervous
but all those people at that table love
you
it's freaking bonkers
how powerful of a purchase is and it's
also made me realize that wow
I am so not used to giving myself that
kind of love and reassurance
no wonder I'm uncomfortable letting
other people give it to me
there really is no one quite like the
singular Casey neistat an icon in many
different senses Casey is the host of
the wildly popular YouTube channel with
over 12 and a half million subscribers
he's an entrepreneur an angel investor a
husband a dad just an overall great dude
smart dude and here we talk about
creativity we talk about filmmaking and
some of the ugly broader truths of the
Creator economy that incentivize
sensationalism
what is the state of the union when it
comes to like the Creator economy or the
influence you know like as as sort of
the grandfather of or somebody who you
know holds some responsibility for
birthing this new you know generation of
of creators like how do you see that
because you usually you have pretty you
know Keen observational skills about
what's going on what's going wrong and
you know how to make it better
sure I I don't know about the latter
about how to make it better but I can
tell you
from afar not even from far I think I
pay pretty close attention it feels like
and this is a bleak
this is a bleak uh response but it feels
like influence is much much more valued
than creativity and that sucks
um and I hope that people take issue
with with me saying that I hope that's
just me being cynical but
you know Tick Tock I think is the most
amazing horrifying both delivery uh
mechanism and creation mechanism I've
ever seen brilliant because I've never
ever experienced an interface that is
just so easy to find new things it's you
don't there's no
sort of cognitive burden there's no like
spending 20 minutes figuring out what
Netflix you want to watch or scrolling
through YouTube to see which which
thumbnail is the most attractive no
decisions there's no decisions to be
made if you're not interested you just
flip it and you're on to the next and
it's a that's [ __ ] incredible slash
terrifying
um and then from a creation perspective
it's fascinating that they've removed
all those barriers they give you special
effects that you can do in camera they
give you the camera which is your phone
they give you amazing soundtracks which
is that I watch this video and I liked
it so I'm just going to use that audio
and it's like they've overcome all of
those creative barriers but at the end
of the at the end of the day I don't
know that that has bolstered creativity
I think what it has done is it has made
the top of the funnel
so much wider than it's ever been like
if the top of that funnel was super
narrow when you know you and I were
really young when we were in the 90s
when to be a filmmaker men being an
indie filmmaker and getting into a film
that was [ __ ] impossible to do
and then it got a little bit wider a
little bit wider and then YouTube and
anybody could now share with the world
but you still have to figure out how to
create and make and all that [ __ ] tick
tock's gotten rid of everything and now
the top of the funnel is wider than it's
ever been
but it still feels like the bottom of
the funnel like really amazing stuff
that you watch and it means something to
you
is as small as it's ever been
um everything is ephemera yeah and on
Tick Tock it's not even about following
people that Intrigue you it's just about
reacting to whatever the algorithm
decides you might want to look at sure
so if you know in the course of a year
I'm making numbers up but if in the
course of the year you see a hundred
things you know paintings or hear songs
or watch movies or YouTube videos or uh
see a picture or watch a tick tock that
affect you that you don't stop thinking
about
um we're now seeing a million
but that number of how many affect you
like that hasn't moved for me I don't
see more brilliant stuff I just see more
stuff
and what concerns me is that that's
what's sort of being celebrated is like
and now it's purely about the metrics
and not about how you achieve those
metrics and that sucks
um
I don't know where that goes I don't
know where that goes from here
um and I don't know what that means like
I had a very
I think eloquent sort of monologue about
how the egalitarianization of filmmaking
is going to main it finally is an art
form that everybody has access to and
we're not going to get to see New
Perspectives and ideas shared in ways
we'd never seen before because you don't
have to go to NYU Film School to make
something
and I think that probably is still true
but we're watching it manifest and it's
not I'm not seeing new brilliant [ __ ]
that's like wow I didn't see that coming
um and that kind of sucks uh it does
make me want to go back and purely focus
on the create the creative and see that
if I can use my platform which is still
big
um to find success yeah that that will
be very reassuring but if I
you know if uh if it if I make stuff
that I still feel like is good and I'm
really proud of and nobody watches it
I don't know what that would be I know
I'd still be saying you still have the
satisfaction of I'll still be psyched
yeah as long as I think it could also be
psyched yeah but it would be telling of
the of where we are right now you know
is somebody more likely to try to follow
in your footsteps or are they going to
Pivot to Tick-Tock where it's just
easier to audience capture and create
these short little things yeah and jump
on Trends to be really cynical it's like
what are you gonna make or are you gonna
be the guy are you going to be like uh
the guys that made everything everywhere
all at once you know there is like some
incredible filmmaking going on dude have
you seen Top Gun yeah it's unbelievable
it's unbelievable like I'm trying to
time it so I can sneak into theaters
just to see that third act over and over
and over there's still good [ __ ] being
made and and I'm really excited about
that
super successful stand-up comedian
writer actor producer and host of the
good for you podcast Whitney Cummings
made a heartwarming and hilarious
appearance on episode 7 18. known for
her stand-up as well as for her sitcom
Whitney she remains underappreciated I
think in her wisdom with issues relating
to mental health which are earned
through her own personal confrontation
and working through a past marked with
anxiety as well as a codependency
Disorder so here's an excerpt lifted
from that very conversation
so what was your Breaking Point with all
of this like how did how did you get
ushered into the rooms
I had a family member go into rehab
um because also I the the Wild Thing
probably very similar to work addiction
is that codependence is incredibly
rewarded it is incredibly rewarded you
are so useful I played Sports really
competitive competitively I was always
the first person to get there the last
person to leave like I was hello yeah
totally just mostly because you guys
organized this wrong
you know we think we're right about
everything because we had an alcoholic
coach who was less reliable to make it
to mornings from practice so I had the
keys
to the pool
and that is a form of trauma that most
people wouldn't categorize under trauma
but it was like and I was proud I was
like yeah I'm reliable I will be there I
will make sure that everybody gets in
we're going to have mornings from
practice which goes oh the authority
figure isn't reliable
I'm on my own you know so as soon as and
that drives the control issues and the
perfectionism because you have great
data that you should have the keys you
know that's the tricky part is like your
mother and you're micromanaging well you
guys suck at this I like there's also a
tricky one because like well I am better
at this than you are maybe not for the
right reasons but I am you know so then
you get to a point where you just go
it's not about that you know and then
when you're leading 200 people there's
no time to act like that and turns out
when you think that you're helping
someone or helping them save time you're
just patronizing them and you're like
telling them I don't trust that you can
do this so I'm gonna do it myself but
the guy says oh you know I'll do it for
you oh I got it no no I got it no
worries you go home but you're really
just saying I don't like the way you do
things I'll just murder myself and do it
and then start to hate you and not even
give you a chance frankly right you know
because we were proven wrong as a kid it
was very hard to trust other people to
do things I had a um
a really brutal uh uh a family member of
mine went into rehab and I was you know
there 24 7 did the intervention bringing
the nutri-grain bars bringing the you
know athletic greens you know just there
every single day what do you need can I
get you a sweatshirt do you need do you
need new shoes do you need comforter I
mean I was just there all day every day
while I was doing two television shows
simultaneously and um
someone pulled me aside uh my now
therapist
um who was the family uh therapist there
she specializes in Neuroscience of
addiction childhood trauma etc etc and
she um she's 30 years sober she's
amazing and she came up to me and she
was just like hey so
you know you're just killing this person
faster
um
and I was like you know but
and of course I had guilts about what
happened to both of us as kids you know
what happened to her not and I just
wanted to fix it with my love and that's
not how neurology works that's not how
younger than you older older interesting
you know and so we both have sexual
abuse in our past which is a very once
you really get a handle on that a lot of
behavior starts to make sense and you
start to go oh wait a second all these
things I do I could actually kind of
like reroute to be incredible tools to
give me a giant Advantage like I
actually think I have a giant Advantage
because of all these things like let me
just perceive it that way you know so
for longest time I perceived my trauma
as exactly what it was the trauma I
didn't block out which we can talk about
later or repressed or completely
disassociate from but I perceived it as
trauma and as a liability and I have two
broken legs and a broken brain and then
as soon as I change my perception on it
I was like oh my God I was like gifted
all these wild superpowers I'm just
using them wrong you know so once I was
able to do that I it my life got pretty
awesome but it took you know 14 years in
Al-Anon and right still sponsoring and
still super involved so when that
therapist was like you're killing
yourself
uh or you're you're actually killing
this person that you love more quickly
because you're not giving them the
Dignity of their own experience and you
can't grow if you do everything well and
you're slowly killing yourself trying to
solve a problem that's not your problem
to solve right but when that lands like
a ton of bricks like does that ring a
bell in you and say I need to go to
Al-Anon or like how did you like walk
into your first meeting well because
then the first thing I did was I went to
the person I was like am I killing you
like is this bad should I not give you a
hundred dollars every day for whatever
you need for groceries yeah but you're
you're asking the unreliable narrator
like of course they're gonna say keep
doing this the drug addict need cash in
rehab yeah so I did the you know
Cardinal mistake which I went back to to
the person and I was like I just talked
to her and she she doesn't she thinks
it's fine when I'm doing like and she
was like okay so
that's hilarious I make I'm like I'm a
hero and I get I don't think you
understand okay like I'm handling this
I've got it and um
she said to me she goes you know there's
a program uh that you know is worth
going to I'd love to take you some time
and you know I was like why why would I
need a program she's the one that won't
stop drinking right come from the same
household Cut From the Same Cloth had
the birth order been reversed it would
have just you know and she goes well I
just watched you go to the problem for
the solution
and I was like yeah that's how you get a
solution like I was like you sober
people are just
you don't get it you know I mean I saved
I'm very busy person I don't so her
whole thing was like no if you have a PR
if your problem is someone else's
Behavior you go to a program to for the
solution because the solution might be
do nothing
the solution might be do not a damn
thing because we're so addicted to
taking an act that doesn't compute does
not compute so then I was like okay I'm
gonna go to this meeting so I can figure
out how to get herself
hahaha
well that's that's the equivalent of
like I'm going to go to a so I can
figure out how to continue to drink
without being an alcoholic
no or people that are like I shoplift
that but I'm just going to the gambling
um 12-step programs because it's
basically a gambling addiction at the
base of it it's like well you're not
okay but yes The Lies We Tell ourselves
and the delusions and look I had a ton
of proof that I was a super high
function as a perfectionist as a
micromanager and as a martyr I had
gotten a lot it makes it harder because
the world is smiling upon you and you're
being wildly rewarded for these
unhealthy Behavior patterns that you're
blindly unaware at some point are really
going to derail you at best and might
actually kill you sometimes we're
hurting people in ourselves and we don't
even know it
what practices do we need to adopt now
in order to live longer live stronger be
more agile and more cognitively fit as
we age well physician engineer and
Stanford Medical School grad Peter attia
MD answered these questions and more on
episode 695 which was kind of a mini
master class on longevity and human
performance
so for your centenarian Olympics like
what are what are the events that you're
working towards like what are the
categories
you know for me I think my kids are the
greatest source of joy in my life so
um you know my hope is that my kids have
kids and that we're in proximity to them
and I just get to do the kind of stuff
with them that I get to do with my kids
right now
um so I again it's silly simple stuff
but again I'm fortunate that you know I
still have two boys that are young five
and eight and so I realize to play with
them is hard like they play on the floor
you know we're building Lego we're
building tracks we're pushing trucks
we're doing that stuff and when I look
at for example my dad who's 85 like he
can't engage with kids like that
and a big part of it is my dad's
mentally as sharp as attack he can't get
on the floor
so something as simple as can you get on
the floor
spend 30 minutes without your back
breaking and get up now that takes a lot
of intra-abdominal stability
you really have to be able to initiate
intra-abdominal pressure to to maintain
that position
um and of course getting up requires a
whole bunch of coordinated activities I
mean I have a very lofty aspiration
which if I get there is great which is
I'm gonna be able to get up without
using my hands still which I can do now
obviously but even if I can just do it
on one point of support that would be
fantastic
um I love archery it is such a big part
of my life and you know even though now
I'm pulling a 75 pound bow I think to be
able to pull a 50-pound bow in my
marginal decade would be fantastic
um I I love driving race cars now Paul
Newman drove a race car until probably a
year or two before the end of his life
so for me that's something that you know
I would love to be able to to be able to
continue to do and that requires not
just the strength and the coordination
and the mental acuity to do it you have
to be able to tolerate insanely hot
temperatures it gets so hot inside of a
race car that you have to kind of have
the kind of cardiovascular fitness to
tolerate that right but having clarity
about what those things are allows you
to then back cast to now and start to
build the foundation for that capability
yeah like we were talking about earlier
I mean that's a big part of why I do
what you do which is I do some of my
activity like I rock four or five days a
week you know carrying a weighted
backpack but I always do it at like five
or six pm so in Austin and that's about
the hottest time of day so it's 100
degrees
sometimes it's 100 506
and you got a 60 pound pack on your back
and you go walk three miles in the Hills
your ability to tolerate heat you know
you go to somebody's barbecue at 11
o'clock when it's 90 and everybody's
dying you're like there's nothing right
um well beyond this kind of Realm when
you think about longevity and when we
talk about longevity we're really
talking about health spam like what are
the other buckets and and I guess a
question that I have is how does this
um kind of line up with you know the
ideas of the blue zones and these other
kind of principles that guide you know
how to think about
um setting ourselves up for longevity
success
well as you said you know lifespan is
sort of a lifespan and health span are
the two vectors of longevity
um but I do think most people think more
about the health span one uh and the
good news is they're not independent
vectors right these are these are
actually not orthogonal vectors there
even though we represent them
orthogonally on a graph
um if you take all of the steps to live
a better life
they're just invariably going to also
lead to a longer life
um now there are exceptions to this rule
there are certain trade-offs one might
make if you were really purely
optimizing on one or the other but the
but the overlap is so powerful so I I
usually tell people not to worry about
it you know in other words if they say I
don't care how long I live I just want
to live the best life possible it's like
great you're going to live longer by the
way
um so so I think of them as I said in
those three buckets sort of a cognitive
bucket a physical structural bucket and
an emotional bucket and
um within that physical bucket just to
kind of round it out you have everything
we've just spoken about which is the
stability component
and that's the foundation everything has
to be built upon that
and then there were like sort of think
of like three pillars that stand on the
foundation strength an aerobic base
which is effectively a proxy for
mitochondrial efficiency and you know
exceptional fuel partitioning and then a
peak aerobic you know slash anaerobic
piece so kind of think of your VO2 max
your Zone 2 and your strength and
um
again I think people have a sort of
intuitive sense of what those look like
but you know the devil is in the details
and you know how much time should you be
spending on one versus the other and
it's really kind of a function of how
much time does is one willing to devote
to this craft right
um I I think you know I think we
for understandable reasons probably tell
people
that they don't need to do that much
exercise because we're talking to the
average person who's doing none and it's
true that if you're doing no exercise
just getting you to do three hours a
week has an unbelievable impact on your
life probably more than anything else
you could tell that person to do
but I would hate for the message to end
there because I think if you're if you
could do 10 hours a week and it's really
well structured you could you know you
the sky's the limit for what you could
achieve
I feel like most people want to eat
better they want to improve their diets
absolutely have you heard of it I've
heard of it this trips up so many people
we thought hey we know a couple things
about how to do this a few so we created
this thing called the plant power meal
planner that is this beautiful offering
whereby you gain access to literally
thousands of plant-based recipes that
you can totally customize based upon
your preferences your allergies your
peccadillos it integrates with grocery
delivery so all the ingredients that you
need get shipped right to your door so
you can make the stuff that you've
pre-selected and we all could use a
little inspiration and support when
preparing meals for our families in our
busy lives so we hope you join us no
matter what your eating style is we have
our arms open wide and we've saved you a
space at our family table to join us in
eating more healthy vibrant plant-based
meals and if you're looking for the
perfect holiday gift for a loved one
right now for limited time we're
offering twenty dollars off meal planner
gift cards through December 15th visit
meals.ritroll.com to claim the offer
again for twenty dollars off meal
planner gift cards from now until
December 15th visit meals Dot
richroll.com
[Laughter]
Gemma Newman MD aka the plant power
doctor is a family medicine specialist
in the UK where she provides
evidence-based nutrition and lifestyle
advice to her patients in this her
second appearance on the show Gemma and
I discussed optimizing Hormone Health
through diet and livestock
um people who have been long-time
listeners or viewers of this show uh
know that I've had all manner of Whole
Food plant-based Advocates on the
program medical professionals including
two recent appearances by our mutual
friend Simon Hill and over the last nine
years
I feel like I've covered most of the
issues regarding this lifestyle and the
role of nutrition and health generally
but one area that I admit to not having
covered with any particular Focus or
intensity is Women's Health specifically
how this differs from General Health
advice and the role of food and hormones
so how do we find our way into this
topic I mean maybe start with some
thoughts about
when you say Women's Health like what
does that mean how is that different
from just human health in general and we
can get more Focus from there yeah so I
mean I did do extra qualifications and
Obstetrics and Gynecology OB GYN you'd
call that yeah and family planning as
part of uh sort of my my work as a
doctor so for a while I worked in Family
Planning as well and
I think it's not that women's health is
over and above different in terms of
nutrition to Men's Health but that there
are various considerations that we would
have physically that that men don't have
um now obviously the the most common
thing would be the fact that we have
periods
um and we are kind of bound by that sort
of natural cycle from the age of uh
puberty to the age of menopause
menopause itself is a huge life
transition which doesn't occur in the
same way with men I think because
primarily because there's less of a
fluctuation and a sort of
um steep decline in hormones relative
you know relevant to Men's Health it's
more of a gradual decline as opposed to
a precipitous one exactly it's much more
gradual and I think that helps to
ameliorate symptoms whereas for women
going through perimenopause
um up to menopause then you can actually
have wild fluctuations of estrogen it
can go way up it can go way down and
that's really what one of the main
things that's sort of responsible for a
lot of the symptoms that women will get
around the Peri menopause which we can I
suppose Define
um but you know hormones affect men too
obviously they affect everybody there's
actually over 50 different hormones and
they have to work together in Synergy in
order for us to perform our best and
it affects every aspect of Our Lives not
just puberty menopause period fertility
but everything mood energy
our skin it affects sperm counts all
sorts of things so it's actually
integral to All Humans but I'd say for
women there are a lot more
considerations especially around
um yeah the fact that we carry children
and that we have periods and that we
have to go through menopause which are
very distinct life phases that do
require extra thought and attention I
think and so what is the role that
nutrition can play in this and also
lifestyle habits so if we talk first
about
um periods perhaps because that's
probably one of the main things that uh
women will focus on from around about
the age of 11 or 12.
um
the quality of your period can change
based on the nutrition that you have so
periods are starting earlier
um which I think is an interesting thing
um I don't think that's just because of
extra nutrition I think there are also
other factors at play
um with regard to environmental
pollutants and things like that I think
there's a lot of reasons why uh girls
are starting their periods earlier and
that's really significant because
essentially that means that our our
growth is kind of done
um we don't tend to get much taller
after we start our periods
um and I think
if you go through puberty and start your
periods too early it can put you at
increased risk of actually things like
heart disease at a younger age I've
never heard that yeah which is a really
interesting thing
um and I think there's just a lot of
extra hormone exposures in our
environment that we haven't been been
able to consider before so meaning like
environmental toxins toxins and skin
care products Etc uh in our foods that
are dysregulating our natural hormonal
Cycles yeah exactly and things that
mimic estrogens in our body uh plastics
for example phthalates BPA they have
hormone mimicking effects which I think
do affect things like fertility and Men
sperm counts but also potentially also
affect when young girls and women start
their periods so yeah there's a lot to
consider now that we haven't really
considered in the past because they
didn't exist
um but I think in terms of practical
things that people can do
increased fiber is so important main
reason being that if you're constipated
you're actually potentially recycling
unwanted hormones through the body
hormones that you would have otherwise
got rid of
um you're actually reabsorbing so trying
to make sure that young girls and well
children and everybody in general
doesn't get constipated is quite a good
way of reducing our excess hormone
exposure
um I think it's important to mention
that you know our fat cells in our body
are also hormonally active they can
produce estrogen so if we have more of
those then we also have more exposures
to estrogen as a result of that which
can affect men as well as women but I
think that's a really important thing
that that again is not necessarily
talked about much the fact that our fat
is also hormonally active too
um and yeah so I think fiber is a really
important thing
um it reduces the hormone exposures it
helps us to produce short-term fatty
acids which also a great for helping our
hormone regulation and feeding our gut
microbiome which is important as well
for hormone regulation which is also
important for our immune system which
affects our hormone regulation so all
these things are linked wait you're
saying it's all related I have
the root of countless problems in our
society lies in a sleeping giant
unhealed trauma author and addiction
specialist Dr Gabor mate returned for
his second appearance on the show and
gave us a powerful primer on the ways
Modern Life is driving us apart from
ourselves and others and fueling mental
and physical disease along the way
all of our afflictions whether it's
addiction
chronic physical illness what we call
mental illness
dysfunctions
they're all have a template of childhood
wounding
and they they're not
separate biological events happening in
discrete individuals
but they are representative of a process
inside each of us that manifests a
relationship to our environment most
importantly our early rearing
environment but also the culture that we
live in so that to give it one example
um
it's an obvious example if you look at
the number of kids going diagnosed with
cadhd the numbers are going up all the
time that can't be an individual thing
that has to say something about the
culture the context if you look at the
rising incidence of autoimmune disease
the rising incidents of addictions of
mental health conditions
if you look at the fact that say black
American women the more experience of
racism they have to endure the greater
the risk for asthma
it just tells us that it's not just
about individual biology it's about
life in a culture yeah and on that idea
of culture you use this petri dish
example to illustrate that point which I
thought was really powerful because I'd
never really thought of it in that way
can you explain that sure so when we are
studying microorganisms in a laboratory
we grow them in a broth we give them a
broth to nourish them you call that a
culture a culture medium
and if the organisms in this culture and
medium his cultural broth we're dying
off in great numbers or not thriving or
or or ill we would call that a toxic
culture
I'm saying that when in a society like
ours more and more people are getting
sick more addicted more mentally ill
more people are cutting themselves
more people are dying of overdoses
that's also the representative of a
toxic culture and saying that that's
what we live in hence the subtitle of
the book trauma illness and healing in a
toxic culture this culture is not a not
one that supports healthy human growth
and when you say toxic culture we should
probably Define that because it's a
little bit different than what people
might suspect they're thinking of
environmental pollutants and the like
and that's certainly a contributor to a
lot of this but you're really talking
about uh what's going on societally and
and culturally yes so that is all true
that it has to do with the physical
stuff there was an article reported just
the other day that half of Americans
were exposed to unhealthy levels of lead
when they were kids you know that's
toxic right but you're right that's not
the toxic that I'm talking about I'm
talking about the nature of the culture
itself the very values of the culture
um the way we bring up children
the expectations we put on human beings
they're toxic to people whose healthy
development it seems so obvious and in
reading the book it's like of course
this is an issue and yet it's so highly
unaddressed or or ignored and in reading
the book I couldn't help but draw an
analogy to what you've all know Harare
is doing in terms of how we think about
history like telescoping out and looking
at everything from ten thousand feet
which is not something we do when we
think about and talk about health we
narrow down to the cellular level to the
microbe level and the scientific method
dictates that we control for variables
and look at things in isolation and of
course we've made tremendous progress as
a society by by Dent of you know the
technological advances that we can make
by utilizing the scientific method but
it's it's a method that's myopic to the
Deep interconnectedness of everything it
doesn't allow us to look at things as
holistic systems and the interplay that
is leading to so many of these problems
like we can't address these diseases in
these conditions on their own without
looking at what's contributing to them
by virtue of external forces well you
know yes I agree with your formulation
but that would also argue that
there's all kinds of science that shows
the interconnections of things so that
to talk about
human beings in a context and that
Health represents life in a context
rather than just a biological event
that's science and we have literally
tens of thousands of
scientific studies to indicate how
emotional environments affect people's
biology or immune system and our
hormonal apparatus and our nervous
systems and our guts and our hearts and
so on and our social conditions our
inequality how stress how
genderism or racism actually has
physiological impacts they go underneath
the skin they affect our biology this is
not speculation my knock on the medical
profession is we keep talking about
evidence-based practice but we don't
look at a lot of the evidence that's
already been published including in
major medical journals so I'm not
talking about
insight and
ideology or or spirituality on the one
hand and science on the other I'm
talking about science that has actually
shown the interconnections but there's
such a wide gap between that
understanding and the practice of
medicine or how we treat people oh yeah
this is a huge what we can call the
science and practice Gap right so the
problem is now with the science the
problem is that we don't put the science
into practice
next up I want to give a spotlight to
the Queen of All Things gut health Dr
Robin shutcan a deep dive into
anti-viral aspects of gut health this
exchange is appointment listening for
anyone trying to better understand the
intricate connection between our
microbiome and our immune system and
what we can all do better to optimize
this relationship
one of the things with the book
I purposefully did not put covet in the
title a book is called the antiviral gut
tackling pathogens from the inside out
and
um while covet is definitely on the
radar there's a lot in the book as you
know you've read it about other viruses
about polio about influenza Etc and when
it comes to Long covet or post-acute
sequality covet or long-haul or all the
different names we have for it
one of the things we know a lot about is
post-viral syndromes this is not the
first post viral syndrome it won't be
the last I think the problem rich is
that we weren't expecting it because we
were thinking this is kind of like a bad
flu virus and post viral syndromes from
flu are not as common but think about
AIDS AIDS is a chronic form
of HIV HIV
the human immunode deficiency virus
causes
AIDS and it causes us prolonged disease
now we have pretty good antiretrovirals
for that but it's still a chronic
condition you think about hepatitis C
can cause cirrhosis of the liver and
liver cancer in many patients you think
about Epstein-Barr virus causes mono
it's been linked to chronic fatigue
syndrome
and
has been linked to Ms now multiple
sclerosis and it's linked to certain
forms of lymphoma so we have lots of
precedent in my world in
gastroenterology we see something called
post-infectious irritable bowel syndrome
post-infectious IBS which is people who
have had a clear
infectious episode and then lo and
behold you know maybe they have acute
symptoms diary or something nausea
vomiting and those acute symptoms
resolve but then lo and behold they have
irritable bowel syndrome and the GI
tract is sort of never the same so we
have a lot of experience with if you
think about some of the sexually
transmitted diseases like herpes and
human papillomavirus so HSV HPV Etc we
know they're acute and chronic forms of
those and we also know similarly who is
at risk for those chronic forms and
there are some outliers to that but we
know for example with in women with
sexually transmitted diseases that the
population of healthy lactobacillus
bacteria in the vagina that produce acid
to repel these viruses that having lower
levels can make you more susceptible to
the acute process of after exposure
becoming infected and also to The
Chronic aspects of that so post viral
syndromes are not new but because this
is a relatively new Iris we're getting
familiar with what the post-viral
landscape looks like with long covet and
there's now there are now more than 200
different symptoms that are associated
and of course
you know a lot of this is reporting
everything sort of gets put in but we
know what some of the more common
symptoms are fatigue respiratory
symptoms brain fog
Etc and if we look at that what we see
are clear microbial differences in a lot
of these patients and a lot of this we
know from the CFS me literature with
chronic fatigue syndrome that
researchers at Cornell were able to look
at the microbiome and identify people
who had
mecfs based on
what was going on microbially and we've
seen a lot of those microbial
differences we don't have a clear-cut
microbial signature yet
but we have some hints and there was a
study that was published in one of our
GI journals they followed 106 patients
with acute covid they found a very high
rate of chronic symptoms about 76
percent and in that 76 percent they
found significant microbial
abnormalities in the people the majority
of people who went on to have chronic
symptoms versus a minority who recovered
very distinct microbial patterns so it's
difficult to sort out how much of that
is cause versus effect because the virus
itself can induce dysbiosis this wasn't
something we talked about but The
Binding of SARS cov2 to those ace2
receptors can induce microbial changes
dysbiotic microbial changes and then of
course dysbiosis itself as we've been
talking about is a risk factor for you
know having worse outcomes so you know
they're both sides to that
we know that autoimmunity is an issue we
see autoimmune markers many of those
patients never had an actual autoimmune
disease before and they still don't have
an autoimmune disease but it's almost
like a a precursor and we don't know
what's going to happen with some of
those patients with the positive anas
and different non-specific markers of
inflammation
are they going to progress to an
autoimmune disease or is that stage
where they are where they have an
autoimmune marker but not an actual
autoimmune disease a specific disease in
an unto itself we see
um EBV plays a role also yeah that was
the thing that jumped out to me that it
could there's a there's a sense that it
might be a reactivation of a virus and
and I didn't realize that like a huge
percentage of people are harboring some
you know amount of that virus the
majority of the population and EBV is
fascinating the history because if we
look at you know 100 years ago
um they called it
idiopathic adenitis I mean idiopathic
meaning unknown adenitis means the the
glands are inflamed and then it was
until researchers at Hopkins you know a
couple decades later linked this to Mono
and then just recently this year some
groundbreaking breaking research linking
the EBV to Ms and the lymphoma
connection has been made a few decades
ago so it's still evolving and the role
that EBV and reactivation of EBV may
play
and non-covet is still you know there's
still a big question mark there but
again we have precedent because we have
lots of research in the MS world in the
lymphoma World Etc so for people out
there who are struggling you know I want
them to know that even though the virus
is novel The Science is not novel we
have a lot of data we have a lot of
researchers a lot we do know and there
you know there are lots of people
working on it
this next clip features New York Times
Reporter Pulitzer Prize finalist and
author of the chaos machine what I think
is one of the most important books of
2022 Mr Max Fisher Max join me on the
podcast to discuss the Insidious ways
that social media platforms shatter our
attention foment Division and Fracture
our world and what we can all do about
that
in your in your reporting on this and
all the work and that you've done and
the people that you've spoken to what
what is the thing that is that that most
shocked you or surprised you about the
extent of this problem I think it was
honestly
learning that
using the platforms it was what we
talked about using the platforms
influences your own sense of right and
wrong even when you're not on them and
it was this sense that it's it's not
just the pizzagate guy it's not just the
Q and on people that it's all of us who
are being distorted by it when I
started to learn about that I you know
really scaled back my social media usage
I turned off a lot of the features
um and I really felt a change I felt the
change in my mood I felt the change in
how I think about politics and the news
that happens if I don't read it through
social media if I just read it through
uh you know regular old websites or
podcasts and I think that
maybe that just shook me the most
because it implicated me
um yeah you know probably objectively I
should be most upset about the fact that
uh Facebook played a major role in a
genocide that expelled the huge
population of Myanmar from the country
but it's hard not to come out of this
thinking
um
that I was affected to without realizing
it and that if that is true for billions
of people including like 80 percent of
Americans then the effect must be pretty
profound yeah this Mass unprecedented
experiment that is being performed on
all of us in real time right without
precedent I mean it almost it's I'm
gonna sound like that guy from Doctor
Strangelove it's almost this like
hope B sci-fi movie where they're
putting drugs in the water and nobody
realizes it and we're all taking it
without realizing it I mean that's more
true than not right you know right
um so when we try to understand
what the possible solution to this is it
it very quickly becomes
incredibly complex and tricky and it
seems to my mind that this battle is
being fought on several fronts on the
one hand we have this argument about
Free Speech right it's free speech being
a core fundamental
premise of all of these platforms that
that you track all the way back to the
Inception of Silicon Valley and the
sensibility of these Founders and these
Engineers so we have the free speech
piece
we have this uh piece about how we
everything can be solved through
engineering which brings up the
algorithm we just need a better
algorithm right to solve this and then
the third piece to my mind is
the reluctance of
the people who are running these
companies to at least publicly
acknowledge the problem or the extent of
the problem and to get into action in
terms of solving it right it's tough
It's really tough when you think about
the corporate incentives because at some
point you're it's like asking cigarette
companies they're antithetical to each
other yeah right right and it just the
the way that our system and our economy
works is you're asking these giant
companies or we're asking these giant
companies to disavow the thing that
makes the money to say that not only are
cigarettes addictive but you shouldn't
smoke them or you know not only is
pumping oil bad for the environment but
in fact we should probably you know
radically downgrade the amount of energy
that we use
um
thank you
this is a question of I think it's more
helpful to think about where you want to
end up and then try to figure out how
you get there than the other way around
because then you try to when you start
with how do we get there it's easy to
say with we'll just tweak the algorithm
that was the solution after the 2016
election is they said well we'll get
better Engineers to come in and have
even more sophisticated algorithms which
of course just made the problem
fundamentally worse
when I would ask people who study this
including a lot of people who are still
in Silicon Valley and are True Believers
what is what's the place that we should
try to aim for to end up it would always
be
some
version of turn it off not turn off the
entire thing because social media does
provide a lot of good that we don't want
to give up but turn off the engagement
maximizing features turn off algorithms
turn off the even Jack Dorsey the former
head of Twitter he for a while was
saying maybe having a little light
counter at the bottom of a tweet is
incredibly destructive to our society
and politics and maybe we should turn
that off yeah later I mean he was kind
of late to come around but in the final
stages of his tenure and the Twilight of
his Reign right he had some real
epiphanies that ultimately were not made
made real right right right and there
was there was a period where he was
pushing against the Financial incentives
of his own company and all the other
companies were growing by Leaps and
Bounds and his wasn't because he was
kind of constraining its growth because
he thought that it wasn't healthy
um
there is a version of social media that
um like any platform of any kind can
have some negative effects to it but the
the pre
2008-2006 pre-news feed pre-likes social
media
um it didn't have a lot of these harms
and it was something that contained a
lot of the good that we
hope for and like and appreciate from
social media without these distorting
effects um and without this kind of
addictiveness and the changes to our
Behavior because they didn't have
engagement maximizing features
prophets Walk Among Us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years I've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing and so I've dedicated my career
to tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
the podcast is not the only medium by
which to share their stories which is
why I'm proud to announce the release of
my new book voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration and Timeless wisdom that
transpires each week on the ritual
podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
Exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying Standalone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday profits and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained
with them
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
while I love all my guests I have to
admit that I've never met anyone quite
like Sylvia Earl a marine botanist
oceanographer and one of the very first
National Geographic explorers in
Residence
also somebody who was named first hero
for the planet by Time Magazine Sylvia
is a straight up living legend now 87 it
was an honor to talk to her about the
Majesty of our critical Blue Waters and
the importance of preserving them
State the case for why ocean health is
so critical I mean you mentioned carbon
capture and how vital the oceans are in
terms of that but why should we care
like why is this so crucial that we do
everything in our capacity to protect
and preserve our ocean system
when I was asked that question
back in the 70s
by a
young woman reporting for an Australian
publication
he just flashed with me that okay
so you don't care about the ocean
because you don't eat fish you don't
swim
people don't drink salt water
if the ocean dried up tomorrow why
should you care
I said okay
you got it dry up the ocean no ocean
what have you got
only about three percent of Earth's
water is not ocean
and that three percent is constantly
being
recharged by the ocean as water
evaporates up into the clouds and falls
back on the land and the sea it's the
biggest Storehouse of water start with
the water all life needs water ourselves
very much included the shorthand version
of that is no blue no green
no ocean no us
so we're not going to dry up the ocean
tomorrow but let's say you just modify
the ocean warm the ocean
make it a generator of more powerful
storms
and more frequent storms make it a
generator
of sea level rise because warm water
takes more space than cold water and
that's part of what we're seeing right
now is the expansion of the ocean
change the temperature to the ocean
either make it colder or warmer and
you've altered one of the most basic
things that we take for granted
the the range of temperature that is
suitable for human existence
and if it's just water it doesn't work
either
it's the living ocean
that makes Earth habitable
and it's taken all preceding history to
develop this closely interacting
system
of systems in the ocean living systems
mostly built of collaborations of
Partnerships
of of this it's like a giant Symphony
and every piece has a a place
and what we have done
in a remarkably short period of time
is to derail up end cut swaths through
disrupt
this amazing
system
that they say it's taken 100 I've taken
four and a half billion years actually
to to assemble and literally about four
and a half decades to significantly rip
apart yeah and we're doing it
with her eyes open with a smile on her
face we have laws to reinforce it
laws protecting shipping laws protecting
industrial fishing
laws
actually
giving subsidies to kill
the ocean right
yeah the subsidies are are a huge
problem right because they provide the
underpinning for all of these systems
that are destroying I mean one of the
more heartbreaking scenes in in Mission
blue is when you travel out in the Coral
Sea right past the Great Barrier Reef
and and you drop in on on what was once
just a you know an epic Reef system and
it's completely dead and just
seeing how you're so far out there in
the middle of nowhere and yet the middle
of everywhere yeah yeah
exactly it's so heartbreaking and yet
you carry yourself with
such conviction and a level of
hopefulness despite all of this evidence
you know you've you were there many
years ago you've seen this Evolution how
do you hold on to that sense of of
hopefulness
well during
2020 when I had to kind of
like most of the rest of the world
sit back and and reflect on questions
such as this you know what reason is
there to Hope in the face of
of so much
so much that's so negative Wars poverty
you know hunger
conflict you know it's you could go on a
list and certainly claim it
and the loss of the diversity of life
Bloom large in my mind
but at that time I was also in the midst
of writing this big book for National
Geographic we have it right here Global
Odyssey right
and although I had thought a lot about
the question what reason is there for
hope
I really
had a chance to
dive in literally
what we now know about the ocean
takes time to sift through the latest
foreign
Explorations latest experiments latest
Reflections latest
studies on on where we are
and also
to reflect on what we don't know which
is enormous you know the more we know
the more we know we don't know it's I've
just been saying that all my life but
we know enough right now to realize
there are things that can be done
positive things every individual
can take action that together magnifies
into a movement into a change of policy
into a new way of thinking about food
there's evidence that we have done this
in the past about smoking about wearing
a seatbelt about you know in overnight
when we realized that our lives were
threatened by a virus
it's not the first time although for the
first time we could quickly identify
what it was
not so long ago the existence of viruses
was not known we didn't even know what
bacteria were not so long ago in human
history
and now we have this ability based and
armed with knowledge
turn around and when we get it to change
it took us longer with seat belts and
smoking
but we got it with covet 19. we have to
get it with climate change and realize
that by protecting nature
recovery is possible
when it comes to personal transformation
there really is no one quite like Ken
ride out a guy who has transcended a
Litany of obstacles including opioid
addiction to become one of the world's
preeminent Master athletes crowned
world's best marathoner over 50 by the
New York Times here's a look into the
mindset Ken is leveraged to create his
improbable success
now the one thing that I um will say I I
heard your um interviews with um David
Goggins I mean I've heard a lot of your
reviews but one of the things that he
said that really resonated with me that
always comes back to my top of mind for
me is that like this is what I do this
is just what I do when I get up to run
it's funny because as you build as you
build some um like mental toughness in
in callous your mind a little bit to the
reality that like this is every day it's
like you know like when you're going
through recovery it's like how the [ __ ]
am I gonna not drink for two weeks like
you don't have to you only have to not
drink for the next hour and then we'll
deal with the next hour that's the
running is like you just have to set a
real goal and if nothing else and I
think it's almost easier late in late
later in life because I've made so many
mistakes in my life and we all have
but today you can start doing the right
thing right now set a goal it doesn't I
always want to be mindful of people's
abilities and and capabilities and say
you don't have to run 10 miles a day but
if you've never run maybe you're going
to start walking one mile a day minimum
and set realistic goals like okay I
don't care like how out of shape you are
that's not that ambitious if you have
something wrong with you that's a
different story but if you're healthy
start with walk in a mile maybe it's
running a 5k if you're capable of that
or 10K but be Dependable to yourself you
it's shocking what how much that can
help you in other areas of your life
when you're Dependable to yourself when
you know I know that when that if the
[ __ ] hits the fan here I know I can
count on myself to do the right thing
when the chips are down left to my own
devices when things are fluffy and cool
and it's easy to make mistakes but if
the chips are down and there's like
something incredibly important happening
like I know I can count on myself
because
and nothing else I've proven that to
myself and I have to you have to believe
it yourself so back to my point about um
David Goggins with this is what we do
when I wake up it never ever enters my
mind and I
I'm so far removed from having a debate
with myself of if I'm gonna run that I
know it might be hard for some people to
hear but like there is never an inkling
of Doubt of like I'm not doing this I'm
tired I'm going back to bed I just think
is it rain oh it's raining damn it this
is gonna suck I hate running in the rain
but I'm doing it and I mean even when I
had the shoulder surgery it was like a
blizzard outside and I was like dude you
can't even see outside it's like a white
out what are you doing I'm like I gotta
do this but I I think that with the
mindset stuff is you have to prove to
yourself that you can do it because I
haven't like you said I have nothing
special I'm I'm every man I'm I'm an
average athlete at best I played
division three football and hockey I was
like Jack of all trades master of none I
was just willing to do whatever I had to
do to stick around to be on the team if
they needed me to fight I'll be like
okay I'll fight but your advantage or
your superpower is your mental game like
I hear somebody who who really
understands
um the idea of non-negotiables like
you're able to commit to something and
follow through with action you know so
it's not about VO2 max or anything like
that I couldn't tell you any of those
metrics it's just about like do you ever
wear a heart rate monitor by the way
like okay sometimes my watch measures it
and it'll put it on Strava and people
will be like dude heart rate of I don't
know 185 blah blah blah I'm like oh that
was my heart rate I didn't even I didn't
even know I know it doesn't make you
strap one on once in a while that's the
best thing about Mario's he knows who
he's dealing with he knows but the point
being like that's that's that's really
like the engine behind all of this is
like that mental discipline right and
that's a muscle just like anything else
that's something you can train just like
you can train your running or your
cycling or what have you 100 I wish that
that was the one thing that people take
away from this is that this guy like I
think of myself as just a Dopey guy
who's made a shitload of mistakes like
anyone else same insecurity the same
fear the difference is I'm not I'm not
letting that control me anymore
fear is such a powerful to such a
powerful emotion whether it's telling
your story to someone or a big meeting
in work or or a speaking gig
the emotions are the same you if you can
learn to deal with those emotions and
and harness that everyone feels in the
same but the people who are successful
learn to harness that and use it as
their own tool whether it's get them
more ready or or
get them to perform at a higher level
and you see it all the time you don't
think that Tom Brady is scared to death
in the fourth quarter when they're
trailing in the Super Bowl you know the
difference is he's feeling the nerves
but he's like let's go he's using his
like right you have a strategy to
channel that into something productive
as opposed to letting it capsize you in
the in the boxing for me was my outlet
that I was scared every time I went
every fight every sparring session but I
kept going because I don't want to be
controlled by fear and it it served me
in a lot of ways in life including
dealing with addiction because when I
was like you know when you're about to
go through withdrawals and entering into
this like uphill battle it is recovery
you're like
I don't want to do it let me just put it
off for a week
and that's
if if you have these tools you're
equipped to deal with all these
different challenges and look it doesn't
make you
um
um
immune to mistakes you're going to make
mistakes but hopefully if you have these
mental tools and I think you can
continue like you said increase the
strength of that mental tool it is
mindset by setting realistic goals for
yourself and working towards them
next up is world record setting
Adventure athlete Arctic Explorer and
New York Times best-selling author Colin
O'Brady as well as his partner Jennifer
saw this power Duo Grace the podcast to
share harrowing stories from Everest and
K2 to discuss the power of an all-day
12-hour walk and share actionable
insights on how to tackle limiting
beliefs
I know you've talked about a lot on the
show rich I think there's a big
difference between belief and abundance
and the belief in scarcity right like
just that belief
um and I was actually listening to you
and skolnik chop it up on the the
10-year anniversary pot of Finding Ultra
you'll have to say say the line but you
said something like when you're living
in your truth the universe conspires
what's the what's when your heart is
true the universe will conspire to
support you I mean I think you ought to
kind of drill down to brass tacks on
that
What I Hear in your story and I've
experienced this myself is that on some
level you have to believe it's possible
and you don't have to completely buy
into that you can have rational
skepticism like wow that's going to be
really hard I don't I don't know if I
can do that but what can I do right now
I don't have any money but I can go do
this and like and I think the more
little kind of steps you take in the
direction of that thing that you you
know dream about or aspire to have in
your life there is energy that kind of
coalesces around that and then the next
step will be reveal you're not I think a
lot of people just sit around and they
want to see how the path is going to
unfold all the way to the end or the
destination and it doesn't work that way
like you have to with each step you get
a little bit more confidence and you get
a little bit more evidence and you know
I can't like pick Iron Man like Iron
Man's expensive yeah you know so well I
want to do an Iron Man I don't have any
money and I don't own a bike but you
know I borrowed my friend's bike and I
wrote for a while and then you know
after doing that for three or four
months this other friend of mine had an
extra bike and he said he'd sell it to
me for like you know 20 percent of what
it's worth and you just you kind of make
it work and then the more that you do
that the more the universe kind of opens
up to you and things happen and that
sounds perhaps a bit too ephemeral or
mystical and maybe even privileged but
I've seen it happen in my life this is
certainly the path that you guys have
have taken like totally things occur
when you just keep pushing forward
incrementally 100 and I think that it
comes also back to
you're gonna get like your buddy didn't
sell you the bike on the first time you
thought about having a bike that might
be like when you're thinking about how
to get a bike for three months and that
finally comes around meaning like you
didn't like give up on your dream to
have a bike after the first you got to
earn the dream I love that after
intelligence and work ethic right yeah
and the more that the more kind of Sweat
Equity you put into it the you know the
more opportunities you're creating for
yourself but it doesn't it doesn't lay
out linearly or on the timeline that you
would prefer right
eventually the person you least expect
to open a door for you is the one who
does and I I mean two two full one
there's a to me there's a amazing Jenna
helped me tell this story but we we were
six eight months into trying to raise
money for the Explorers Grand Slam
project and had raised very little a
triathlon sponsor of mine had a guy High
net worth guy named Brian caliber who
would help me out for smartest I've said
I'll help you once you show me you can
have some proper sponsors like I'm not
just gonna write your check so show me a
Nike sponsorship show me like a real
quote-unquote sponsorship and then I can
maybe Matt you know help you guys out so
that was a big thing
only if we could prove ourselves
basically right but it's like there's a
little shred of Hope like okay there's a
crack here like now I have something to
work with but then six eight months down
the road we still had raised in
basically zero dollars and we finally
Buy
you know friend of a friend of a friend
had introduced us to someone at Columbia
Sportswear who had introduced us up the
chain at Columbia Sports where after
five people said no and we actually get
a meeting with Tim Boyle who's the CEO
of
um Columbia Sportswear based in Portland
um and they also own Mountain Hardware
and Sorel and a bunch of the other like
you know whatever climbing Brands and
we're like oh my God this is our big
shot like this is our big shot
we prep for the meeting Jen and I are
like did we like read his mom's book
about the starting of the company we
would do all the things we like buy
their clothes to go to the office and of
course we couldn't afford
and we walk in and
he sits down and he looks at us the
first thing is he's kind of like who are
you guys and you realize like we've been
prepping for this meeting and this is
like two minutes in between something
actually important that he's taking and
we're like oh shoot we like we're ready
with this whole pre we're thinking he's
gonna give us the time of day to like do
the poll presentation we're like well we
have this like website with like a video
on it and like whatever we like play it
for him and you can just see his eyes
just kind of like glaze over and he's
like cool cool like uh hey good luck
with that like good job you guys good
luck with that and we're like bringing
ushered out the door and Jenna is just
a complete Savage like I was like well I
was like I was like this can't be it
like this cannot be the end of the road
for this because you know in looking
through all the different sponsorship
opportunities I was you know when you
just can feel something is right I'm
like this is the one we cannot let this
slip through the cracks and I just
pivoted and said like Mr Boyle like
Colin here's a local guy from Portland
you haven't even heard his whole story
give me five minutes to tell you
what you need to know here and I just
truly from the heart like I and I am not
one to just like raise my hand and speak
up and like you know jump into the
middle of something and it just came out
so organically and so naturally I shared
exactly what we were trying to do how
much money we were trying to raise and I
think he's just for the Explorers
we had nothing and Jenna what she's
being humble Jenna is generally a really
a natural introvert and
um
just uh I don't know you're not one to
just like you but in that moment to be
like actually excuse me Mr Boyle like he
was like what like I just thought that's
like who's this girl 27 year old girl
sitting in the corner and she's like
Excuse Me Miss Pearl actually I think
there's a little more it's like to this
like you know high-powered CEO and she
kind of sits him back down in his chair
and just goes like goes in it's like
there's more here so I think it's a
combination of that belief in abundance
which is to even get that meeting it was
like no no no yes meet a guy at a coffee
shop who could introduce you to Here
There and both of us like doing that but
also in the moment like you're in this
moment and you're like okay I could just
use inflection points where you know you
have to crush it yeah and they're saying
the guy's saying no he's literally
saying no and Jenna's just like I was
even like I think both of us really
lived by this quote a closed mouth is
never fed and it was like I hadn't even
had the chance to ask for what we wanted
before getting shut down and I was like
oh no this is the moment where you have
to speak up and you have to say at least
if you get to know you get to know right
right but it was a really beautiful
Exchange change and ultimately led to
our like first legitimate like real
sponsorship right so what is what did
what did you say specifically that
turned the tide
question I mean I wasn't recorded so I
don't know exactly you know specifically
what I said but I really I was like
Colombia wants this and needs this like
I can see this for you guys as a brand
this is critical to what you're trying
to
um use as a campaign and they were doing
and tested tough tested tough yeah and
again this was years ago
um and it's just like everything that
the project was sharing out in the world
was exactly the same talking points as
this campaign
um and I think I just kind of you know
gave a little bit from my standpoint she
just she just locked in was just like
I'm not taking like he was just like
whoa she's not taking no answer okay
well it sounds to me like it was a it
was like a Vibe shift from hey you know
we need this for us to here's how we can
fulfill your need which is to extend
your brand Awareness on this messaging
that's completely on point with what
you're trying to do and not for nothing
you're not really doing a very good job
on it right now and in a really unique
way exactly like I was like what we are
bringing you're not going to get
anywhere else like this is Colin can
bring this we can bring this as a team
and like you want this not in like a you
know
crazy way but just in a very complete
honest way and I think he saw that I
think he finally saw the passion and was
willing to take a risk on us and yeah I
mean that that was a huge turning point
but it certainly was not it wasn't going
to pay for the balance of what we were
doing it was just to be like oh you know
you know a domino had fallen like whoa
Columbia Sports project that that
allowed us sort of the ability to kind
of go out in the world but then yeah we
were still a lot a lot of dollars short
you know of raising money for this first
project and
um you know basically just kept knocking
on doors and I think you know my mom
said this to me for a long time I don't
know if it's her quote I'd probably not
but she says you know luck comes to
those who are prepared
um and you know getting our first
project off the ground was two and the
two of us waking up every single day
with our mind flooded with doubt right
like our mind flooded with all these
doubts like oh this isn't gonna work
this isn't gonna this but then getting
up and doing it
if there was a singular theme to 2022 on
this podcast it's that every single one
of us is affected by trauma though some
carry a heavier burden than others and
one of the most important episodes in
the history of this podcast psychiatrist
Dr Paul Conti teaches us how to
understand trauma how to heal it and
ultimately how to prevent it
here's an excerpt from our conversation
back on episode 705.
give me a sense of how pervasive this
epidemic of trauma is because I think a
lot of people when you say the word
trauma it conjures you know an image of
of being sexually abused or being you
know victimized by some very violent act
when in fact there's a broader
definition at play here I just know that
my kind of introduction to these ideas
came at the hands of of Gabor mate we
had a podcast and he did what he does
which is he flips it and it becomes like
a session we start talking about my
upbringing and I I grew up you know my
parents took care of it everything was
pretty good I have nothing that I can
point to in my past that would ring a
bell and say that was a traumatic
experience but the more I've kind of
excavated that the more I realized that
you know I did suffer some my parents
are good people and they're well
intentioned but there was some traumatic
experiences there and it's really
reframed how I think about trauma in
terms of how it it lies on a spectrum so
you know talk a little bit about that
sure so remember going back to the very
first
um aspect of this conversation right
like a trauma is something that leaves
the brain different going forward right
so it's not just anything negative that
happens because people say what about
post-trauma resilience well yes if we
Define trauma differently right
something that really hurts us inside
isn't something we're built to be
resilient to right something that
doesn't do that right that strikes us as
a way oh that was negative we can
respond to with resilience right but
what you're talking about and how we're
framing this is though that like there's
a neurobiological anchoring to trauma in
that it overwhelms us and then we are
different going forward right and
nowhere is it written they're like oh
that only happens if you're in a
terrible accident or if a loved one dies
or if someone assaults you right those
brain changes can happen in other
situations as well we know that to be
true so for example chronic trauma so if
we could break it down into there are
acute traumas chronic traumas and
vicarious traumas the acute of course
more easy to understand but the chronic
trauma of of
for example being framed as less than in
the world whether that's because of
sexuality or socioeconomic status or
immigration status whatever it may be
that often is imposed upon people that
where there's just a constant message
that says you're less than right or of
course there's equality but then there's
a wink that says but not for you right
because you're this whatever the
minority characteristic is right that
the majority is looking down upon and
stigmatizing right and
like it's just so clear that if you if
you sit with people who've been subject
to that for a long time not all of them
but a significant subset have the same
kind of clinically evident brain changes
as people who've had the acute trauma
right now the world is not a safe place
and you don't quite really believe
anything positive and even if it seems
like everything is positive it's still
going to go against you right and then
all this is internalized why because
that chronic trauma can change the brain
the same as acute trauma and sometimes
it can even be things that are seen as
positive right so the idea of you know
the the quote unquote special child
who's like wow you're so good and you're
so smart and and like you're going to go
so far like there's all these
expectations right and then it becomes
very hard to shoulder when they're
disappointments around their things so
then a little bit of Shame becomes a lot
of Shame right and then the thought of
like oh I've been less than perfect do I
messed something up or whatever there
may be can can be intolerable to a
person right and I think that was part
of my AI problem having been like a
firstborn child of a firstborn child and
and then having been pretty successful
in school and the thought was like oh
you're just going to do great things
like everything's going to be great
right well everything wasn't great right
and I needed to realize like look
everything cannot be great and I can
still go make a good life
for myself right so I think it's part of
why some of the things that happened to
me made those changes because I was sort
of set up to be intolerant of anything
less than perfection in myself which
came from a good loving place you know
in the people who nurtured me but
nonetheless
set me up to be very intolerant of
anything that was less than how I
thought it should be so so yes The
Chronic traumas can come from lots of
places and and we know that this can
happen through vicarious trauma you know
thank goodness we have empathy as humans
so we can feel for one another and and
that's part of why we want to help one
another right but empathy also means we
can feel sometimes in very deep ways
other people's trauma you know which is
why
in the last I don't know it's five to
ten years or so I've found myself and I
think a lot of clinicians have found
themselves much more saying to a person
like look my prescription to you is no
more news right or check the news so
that you learn what's new right but why
you know why is the person checking and
rechecking and rechecking and rechecking
because there are all these messages
that tell us like we are not safe and
then the parent is is reading over and
over again this the story of the parent
who lost a child in in a school shooting
I mean things that are
immensely difficult to to shoulder right
and they're out there and we become
fascinated because we we want to think
inside like look I could survive
something like that right so we're so
we're fascinated with it and and you
know and find it to be so abhorrent and
unimaginable but but drawn to it in a
way that if we can have more of an
understanding maybe there could be some
sense of like right if awful things
happen to me I can survive them but
inadvertently what we often do is just
bring more and more and more trauma and
more and more and more lessons so to
speak that say Hey you just can't keep
yourself safe in this world perhaps a
few words for the person that we've kind
of walked to the edge of the cliff here
you know I'm thinking of the person who
hadn't really thought too deeply about
these issues and now is in a place of
thinking maybe there's something I need
to look at here how do I begin to do
that perhaps some encouragement and and
maybe a few really basic tools to help
that person wrap their arms around uh
you know the Fantastic journey to come
yeah
you know
I would say
you don't have to be afraid of what's
inside of you
and we often get very afraid of what's
inside of us especially after trauma
when the trauma itself makes fear and
can make shame that we become very
afraid as if there's something magical
just off I can't see in my peripheral
vision and if I like really look at that
that's the I'll start crying and never
stop or I'll stop functioning and it's
just not how it works it's just not how
we work that if we're careful about it
you know we don't want to say just go
talk to everyone about it right but
we're thoughtful what's going on inside
of me can I put words to it could I talk
to someone right and running current to
like the strength of what says no you
can't do that right everyone will be
ashamed no one will look at you in the
same way you won't be able to function
right like
you know as we talked about much earlier
on it's in the surface of survival right
but that's through an aspect of human
evolution that's not applying now in the
ways that we're talking about so if we
honor and validate that that's in us but
also recognize that it's not actually
true that confronting the thing that
makes shame or fear is going to make us
fall apart and in fact quite the
opposite I mean there's so much data and
clinical experience telling us the exact
opposite that we don't have to be afraid
of it and we don't have to rush headlong
that we can be careful and judicious and
you know you can talk to somebody a
little bit or you can write a little bit
you know that we don't have to be
afraid of it you know it's not some
mystery that makes makes us deer in the
headlights and then we can't function
it's just we can approach it like
anything else you know judiciously
carefully reflectively that's how we
make ourselves healthier yeah
this next clip is courtesy of Ed Winters
a vegan Advocate and animal rights
activist globally known as Earthling Ed
on the internet Ed is an educator he's a
public speaker an author and content
creator with a large cult following on
YouTube I think he's in residency at
Harvard University right now in any
event this conversation was a tremendous
breakdown on veganism from all Vantage
points for both Skeptics and the
converted here is Earthling Ed
one thing I often ask people is you know
are You Against Animal Cruelty and we
all say that we are people who commit
cruel acts to animals as seen as some of
the worst people that can exist and we
really look down upon violence towards
pets like dogs and cats and and such but
we turn a blind eye to the crow to this
inflicts on farmed animals and indeed
animals that have exploited in other
ways as well so when I ask people are
You Against Animal Cruelty what I'm
trying to do I suppose is highlight that
contradiction our values you know when
we say about cruelty and I say to people
can you define what that means to be
cruel to someone you know people will
always say that it's about causing
physical or mental you know emotional
harm so we're doing something
unnecessary that negatively contributes
to someone else's well-being and then
when we think about what we do to
animals of course it's cruel you know we
mutilate them we exploit them we
forcibly impregnate them we take their
babies away from them and then we take
their life from them prematurely for an
unnecessary reason I mean to me that's
like the definition of being cruel to an
animal so I realized that in that moment
thinking about the KFC thinking about
the chickens and realizing that there
was this kind of disalignment in the
person I thought I was when it came to
animals and the person I actually was
and so I kind of reached this fork in
the road if you're pardon the pump but
this fork in the road where I could
choose to kind of bury my head in the
Sands and hopefully repress those
feelings and just get on with my life
and not worry about animals anymore or I
could accept that something not quite
right with my values and my actions and
I chose the latter and went vegetarian
because I didn't know anything about
dairy or eggs and then I saw earthlings
which is documentary that exposes what
happens in U.S farms and slaughterhouses
the movie we all begrudgingly watch
right exactly we have to get dragged or
watching it and then we're never the
same it is a hard watch isn't it it's
like an hour and 40 minutes of objective
I guess undercover hidden camera footage
that just shows what happens to animals
and after that I went and spent time
with Rupa the hamster so he was my first
real pet and I don't like to use the
word Pat so much but more like Companion
Animal you know he was kind of my
companion and I had Rupert in my hands
and I was looking at Rupert the hamster
and I gave him some broccoli because
broccoli was his favorite food he loved
broccoli absolutely loved it so I gave
him some broccoli and I was looking at
Rupa eating this broccoli of his cute
little paws he always looked so adorable
and I was looking at him thinking
there's so much about Rupert that
creates moral worth for him you know
he's an individual he has likes and
dislikes and he loved the broccoli but
he didn't like other things like kale
for example you know he had likes and
dislikes things that made him Rupert the
hamster and I thought all the animals
who were exploited and
all the different ways to exploit them
you know I wasn't eating meat but I was
still consuming Dairy and eggs I was
still perpetuating systems that
exploited animals and other means and it
really dawned on me in that moment that
the issue of what we do to animals isn't
just really about food you know food is
a symptom of the problem the problem is
a mentality that creates the
justification for these systems to exist
in the first place the fact that we view
non-human animals are these non-human
animals with such little worth that we
can then justify doing everything that
we do to them that's the problem and I
realize that veganism isn't just about
eating plant-based food it's about
challenging that mindset that values
non-human animals as having such little
worth that we can do these unspeakably
cruel things to them and not bat an
eyelid about it most of the time
a lot of people have an analogous
experience where their witness to some
you know type of animal cruelty and
they're compelled to kind of reckon with
how that measures up against their value
system but not that many people use that
as a lever or Tipping Point to actually
make change I mean there's so much
packed into that there's the level of
cognitive dissonance this idea like you
know we all Flinch and look away from
things like earthlings and
slaughterhouse videos and stuff like
that for the very reason and you talk
about this like the very reason that it
will compel us to confront that
dissonance and if we do that then
perhaps we either need to make that
change that we don't want to make or we
have to live with that level of
Disconnect which creates kind of like
you know just a lack of integration with
just being human right so you had this
moment like what was it about your
background or you know leading up to
that that you were kind of primed to
make that change that so many struggle
make well I think that we often well as
vegans we often think of this one moment
you know I saw earthlings that made me
vegan but what we forget or don't often
realize is that throughout our whole
life there are all these little moments
that are building up to this this kind
of realization and so throughout my
whole life you know I was raised with
this mentality that you know animals
should be cared for you know the people
that do bad things to animals are wrong
but we should you know try and protect
our environment you know I was raised
with these values I was raised with the
I guess the concept that a world with
reduced suffering is preferable so this
was kind of like the mentality I had but
I'd never really connected all of these
components with you know being vegan or
with the consequence of not being vegan
so for me it was just like this I
suppose domino effect of thinking about
these different points in my life you
know for example
um I stopped going to zoos before I
stopped eating meats and dairy and eggs
and the reason I stopped going to zoos
is because I had seen the documentary
Blackfish and the documentary black
which made me not want to see and go to
aquariums but then I went to Barcelona
zoo and in Barcelona zoo I saw a bear
and this bear just looked so solemn and
so sad they were just sat just sat down
in this very small enclosure looking
around and I kind of followed their eyes
they looked around the enclosure and
looked at the four walls they were
trapped in and it dawned on me that
these animals are also being kept in
captivity like the orcas at Sea World
are so then I left I left Barcelona zoo
and never went to another Zoo after that
so I had these kind of moments that made
me realize that what we're doing to
animals isn't something that's good for
Animals it's definitely not but also is
something that contradicts kind of the
values that I have towards how we should
treat them and really just this last
piece of the puzzle was just been kind
of confronted if you like with the
objective reality of you know this is
what you're paying for when you go into
supermarket and you buy this you know we
may we may view these decisions as being
unconscious because they they are
unconscious but they have this very real
tangible consequence that we often don't
think about and so I was forced to go
when I go into a supermarket when I go
into a restaurant or wherever it is and
I give my money to these industries I am
personally funding these very things
that I'm feeling very upset about to
continue and how do I as a person who
wants to reduce suffering who thinks
that a world that you know obviously
we're never going to create a Utopia but
a world that is trying to reach that
Utopia as much as we can how does pain
for slaughterhouses to exist
how does that work in this kind of
vision of the future that I would like
to live in it doesn't so it was all
these little moments but then this just
this overarching realization that I'm
not living in alignment then I'm
fundamentally a hypocrite when it comes
to my treatment of animals and that was
the final piece to go there is a problem
here that is bigger than just this food
problem it's a mentality issue and as a
consequence of that I have to be that
example of what I want to see right
a hot topic of 2022 was aging and
Longevity and Chip Conley graced us back
on episode 681 to teach us how to
reframe aging not as something to fear
but rather as something aspirational and
opportunity to share a crude wisdom and
leverage it to make your life and your
relationships more meaningful
the The Narrative we have about aging is
you you age you work you then you're
tired you have three stages in life you
learn to your 2020 or 25 you earn until
you're 60 or 65 and then you retire to
you die
and if you look at a millennial today
they're like what the hell is that
tyranny of the three-stage life you know
I want to actually work I'm going to
learn until I'm 20 or 25 and then I'm
gonna
work for 10 years and then I'm gonna
take a year off I'm gonna do a gap year
and then I'm gonna go get a masters I'm
Gonna Learn again and then I'm gonna go
retire I'm gonna work for 10 years and
start a company and then retire and then
go back and get a PhD and you know it's
more episodic it's not like you have
these three stages of life
um that are age defined and um
so that you know that led us you know
the mea becoming very popular and uh led
us to creating regenerative communities
and these idea of let's get rid of the
idea of retirement communities yeah this
is the real exciting part which are you
going to live in a retirement community
someday it's the it's the most
depressing horrific you know aspect of
our culture to just Warehouse old people
and hide them it's a form of age
apartheid let's like take those people
and put them in a place where we can't
see them so they're with each other and
and let's also recognize that frankly
earlier Generations sort of saw it and
you know our parents may have enjoyed it
but
there's also this weird sense that you
know back in the old days if you were
working on the factory floor
or you were
um you know you were a school teacher
you know your whole life you got to 60
and you said Thank God I'm retiring
because I can't do that the factory four
work anymore or I'm just so tired of
this
work or you know being a house cleaner
or whatever it was and you know we have
a lot more knowledge workers today and
the and I think we have a lot more
wisdom workers that's a phrase that I
think is going to come into being but
the knowledge workers can they can work
till their 70s or their 80s or whenever
it's not physical labor that actually
defines how they get paid
and so more and more of them are of the
mindset like I'm I don't want to retire
and or I can't afford to retire if I'm
gonna live till 90 or 95 I can't retire
at 62. and also that generation is is
far more inclined to be pursuing work
that has personal meaning to them then
you know we're we're our Legacy is that
that three chapter kind of approach to
life that's what our parents did and we
kind of were reared with that
sensibility and now we're in our 50s and
60s
and a lot of us are having those kind of
Crisis moments but over the course of
those many decades leading up to it
there is a calcification around mindset
this is who I am this is what I do
here's what I can expect for my life
here's how I see the world this is the
people that I vote for and this is you
know these are the things that I talk
about so one of the critical kind of
tools that you leverage at the Modern
Elder Academy that I want to hear a
little bit more about is just getting
really clear on what your mindset is so
that you can begin the process of
deconstructing it and perhaps you know
telling yourself a new story yeah well
so there's four key
um pillars of our curriculum the first
one is reframing aging helping people to
see that maybe their best life their
best years are ahead of them right can
this be aspirational it can be and you
know some things get better with it I I
love that your your listeners and your
community is very much about keeping the
body alive and but but you don't your
certain things get actually better with
age you you know your emotion your
emotional intelligence grows with age
your spiritual awareness grows with age
so there's a lot of things actually get
better with age and and yes if you work
on your body and your health and your
nutrition it might get better with age
as well
uh you're a great example of that so
there's that reframing aging then
there's mindset so there's growth in
fixed mindset we're big fans of Carol
Ducks work at Stanford and so a fixed
mindset is when you tend to think of
life as I'm here to prove myself and I
define success as winning
the problem if you have that point of
view as you get older is you stop
playing the games you can't win
and that means your your sandbox gets
smaller and smaller and as it gets
smaller you actually get more bored
because you're not trying new things so
moving from a fix to a growth mindset
means moving from proving yourself to
improving yourself and instead of
focused on focusing on winning you focus
on learning
and so you move into this way of
thinking and way of being of okay I am
just a learning machine I'm not a
machine I'm a learning human
uh one of the questions we ask at mea is
what is it that you know now or have you
done now that you wish you had known or
done 10 years ago think about that for a
moment
and then ask yourself 10 years from now
what will you regret if you don't learn
it or do it now and this is how I
started to learn how to surf at age 57.
um because I live on a beach near a surf
break somewhat famous one I was like
ain't gonna be any easier at 67 than 57
ship so I gotta start learning that I
also you know started learning Spanish
again the Mantra in my head the mindset
was I'm too old for this too old to
learn the language but harder to learn
at 67 than 57 and I knew that I was
going to be living in Mexico so why not
learn it so so the first is reframing
Agent the second is Shifting your
mindset the third is learning about
transitions
none of us were taught you know and got
a masters in TQ transitional
intelligence but midlife is full of
transitions life is full of transitions
life is liminal you're usually in
between two things
and yet we've never really been taught
you know what are the what's the anatomy
of a transition and how do I architect
moving through a transition whether it's
getting divorced or you know
um changing where I live or changing my
career or retiring or seeing my parents
to passing away or becoming an empty
nester or going through menopause or men
go through andropause there's a lot of
transitions in midlife
um and learning how to understand the
three stages of a transition is a big
part of our program and then the final
piece of the curriculum is regeneration
in all its forms we have regenerative
cell therapy I mean stem cell work
regeneration through understanding a
regenerative purpose but also and this
is where Paul Hawkins comes in
regenerative agriculture right and
farming and that's what leads us to our
regenerative communities which our first
one being in Baja with 26 homes around a
regenerative farm so instead of living
on a fairway wouldn't you like to live
on a farm and and go out into the farm
and go Harvest with your neighbors and
do a potluck once a week and so now
we're taking this to Santa Fe and we
have three different properties in Santa
Fe two of which will be academies one of
which will be a regenerative residential
Community
um and I do believe that we are creating
something that is meant to disrupt
Senior Living
okay that's it that's a wrap on 2022 I
really hope you guys enjoyed that
reflection in the rear view and found
these past two episodes uplifting and
inspiring thank you again for all the
love for all the support this podcast
really has been an amazing journey and
I'm just so grateful you're on it with
me
and I look forward to growing and
learning together in in New Year ahead
so happy New Year everybody until 2023
peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]